The answer to that question is yes. It correlates.
The more experience, the higher the bug density.
This may come as a surprise to you, but here is the story behind it.
We mined the Eclipse bug database and check for the experience and contributions
of the individual developers.
It turned out that the Eclipse project lead, Eric Gamma,
had the second highest defect density in his code across all the developers.
Now, Eric Gamma is anything but a nobody.
He gave the world unit tests.
He gave the world design patterns.
And he gave the world the Eclipse programming environment,
always with a team of course, but still.
Why would his bug density be the second highest across all Eclipse developers?
The reason is simple.
Suppose this is you. You have been assigned to fix a bug.
You look at the problem and you find, oh, this is terribly hard.
What you do is you delegate the problem to your boss,
who is way more experienced than you,
Now your boss is looking at the code and says,
"Ahhhhh...this is something I can't handle."
He delegates this to his lead, and this guy says,
"Ah, this looks really, really, really hard.
Only one person in the world can do that."
This is Eric Gamma, the team leader, who has no one else to delegate to.
Being that the team leader, he gets the toughest problems--
that is, those problems where the changes of screwing up are highest.
Still, he is the man, because anybody else dealing with these problem
would, on average, make a worse job than Eric Gamma.
This is how the more experienced people get the tougher tasks,
possibly introduce more defects, but still overall they are precisely
the right persons to do the job.